nous sommes avec ladislas poniatowski
sénateur de l'eure sénateurs les
républicains de leur rapporteur de la
commission spéciale sur le break site au
sénat bonjour je vous remercie d'être
avec nous boris johnson doit prononcer
tout à l'heure un discours historique et
le prononcera n'ont pas de londres n'ont
pas depuis londres et ce n'est pas
anodin non ils le proposent de l'endroit
où il a gagné les élections législatives
il a fait un score époustouflant dans le
nord de l'angleterre
c'était un endroit où les travaillistes
étaient très fort et il a raflé toutes
les voies entre guillemets travaillistes
qui ont voté pour le président qui se
sont reportés et qu'ils soient vues
conservatrices
c'est devenu un fief de boris johnson et
ce n'est pas innocent parce que il a en
plus fait beaucoup de promesses dans
cette région c'est une région qui est
pauvre
anciennement industriels il a promis
plein d'infrastructures on va voir si
oui ou non il va tenir ses engagements
boris johnson qui finalement a gagné son
pari il avait promis ce break site dans
quelques heures ce sera effectif oui il
a gagné il a gagné incontestablement
mais attendez aujourd'hui est important
pour lui pour eux pour les briques
sitter pour les antilles briques sitter
mais en fait tout commence rien n'est
réglé
à partir de demain le 1er février rien
ne change jusqu'à la fin de cette haine
actuellement jusqu'à fin décembre rien
ne change mais je suis assez pessimiste
sur la possibilité de tout régler en 10
mois ce sont pas quelques accords
ce sont des centaines d'accords en
domaine financier
dans le domaine social dans le domaine
commercial qu'il faut régler
je ne vois pas comment l'angleterre aura
les moyens de régler et les problèmes
avec les vingt-sept et les mêmes
problèmes individuellement avec le japon
avec les états unis avec la chine et à
mon avis n'est pas capable de faire il
n'a pas les moyens c'est trop court et
surtout à qu'il fasse attention parce
que l'europe est très forte pour les
négociations
nous avons en matière commerciale par
exemple les meilleurs négociateurs au
monde
l'angleterre n'a pas le royaume uni n'a
pas négocié un seul traité commercial
depuis 50 ans donc à mon avis sera pas
capable mais il a une porte de sortie
il peut entre aujourd'hui le 15
hier donc avant le 15 juillet dire on
s'en sortira pas j'ai besoin de deux ans
supplémentaires et lui dis je
aujourd'hui il dit je ne demande rien
mais je pense qu'il pourra pas faire
autrement que de demander un délai
supplémentaire de deux ans pour tous et
les mairies négocier mais rien
absolument rien du tout n'a été négocié
quant aux futures relations vous le
rappeliez avec l'union européenne avec
les états unis avec le japon vous avez
raison complètement mais souvenez-vous
le débat s'était dit il on le néo dire
on va vers un accord on n'y va pas non
on est tous d'accord pour aller vers un
accord on est conscient que ce serait
trop difficile de ne pas qu'il n'y ait
pas d'accord mais le nom accor est
encore une épée de damoclès au-dessus de
la tête de la grande-bretagne et de la
tête des 27 c'est toujours possible si
si on voit qu'il ya trop de sujets qui
bloque et avant la vie et le débat et
c'est là où je fais confiance à barnier
qui va du dossier pour la france
depardon europe
excusez moi pour ne rien lâcher je veux
dire comme on veut pas tout régler il va
y avoir des choses qui vont être réglés
prioritairement est alors quelles sont
justement les priorités sur quel point
est ce que l'union européenne ne doit
rien lâcher on a pris position et la
présidente de dieu européenne à
président de président de la commission
qui est de dire on veut tout négocier on
veut pas charcuter on veut pas négocier
petits morceaux par petits morceaux et
laisser monsieur boris johnson choisir
entre guillemets c'est petit morceau à
lui ça serait trop facile qu'ils
puissent demander là où c'est plus le
plus important le plus intéressant pour
lui et nous laisser faire
nous ne nous laisserons pas faire il ya
un autre point sur lequel nous ne nous
laisserons pas faire non plus et vous le
savez on en parle beaucoup partout dans
la presse et chez vous dans les télés
les radios on ne se laissera pas se
créer un dumping
c'est à dire laisser l'angleterre
devenir une sorte de lieu d'attraction
fiscale sociale commerciale pour attirer
tous les avantages non là ne nous
laisseront certainement pas faire on
parle d'un futur singapour c'est sur ce
point là il faudra ce que l'union
européenne devra se défendre et négocier
au mieux ce bonne guerre de la part de
john a
boris johnson est désormais de laisser
entendre que l'angleterre et l'autre
pourraient devenir un singapour européen
et c'est trop facile de dire ça il a un
discours de politique intérieure à son
opinion publique
et puis il ya les négociations beaucoup
plus sérieuses et importantes entre lui
et nous les vingt-sept et là ça sera
nous serons dans le dur
il ya d'un côté les vingt-sept de
l'autre les états unis aujourd'hui c'est
l'un contre l'autre dans ces
négociations un commercial quel camp
choisir tôt mais boris johnson c'est la
question qu'il faut se poser comment est
ce qu'on peut dire ça c'est pas l'un ou
l'autre
l'angleterre est totalement liée à nous
dites vous bien que 47 % des
exploitations anglaises vont vers
l'europe et 53%
les importations anglaise vient des
vingt-sept vers l'angleterre
vous pouvez pas faire disparaître cette
masse des changes comme héros important
pour toulouse pour leur intérêt pour
deux on peut pas faire disparaître ça du
jour au lendemain lancry les états unis
ne peuvent pas remplacer l'europe même
si je ne doute pas que johnson obtiendra
certains avantages certaines conventions
de belles négociations que s'agit mais
on ne peut pas remplacer des états unis
par l'europe ce qui signifie que c'est
un véritable jeu d'équilibriste
aujourd'hui pour boris johnson n'a
jamais votre mot est très bien choisi
la tâche va être très bien sûr premier
league je pense que ce sera ce sera du
donnant donnant on a je pense que le
prestige est pas changé d'avis mois
quand vous aviez reçu d une fois je
pense qu'on est un peu tous perdre en
angleterre des 27
l'europe est perdante par rapport au
reste du monde une europe à 28 était
plus forte
donc je pense que les perdants tous
perdants mais on peut très bien avoir d
une question qui fait qu' aucun ne perde
trop et je pense que c'est un équilibre
à trouver dans tous les domaines
différents pour que l'angleterre ne
perde pas trop
et pour que l'europe ne perde pas trop
un tout dernier mot qu'est-ce qu'ils
jouent qu'est-ce qui va se jouer pour
paris pour la france dans ces
négociations ont dit nous allons devenir
une place financière vont prendre une
partie de l'angleterre c'est vrai qu'une
partie des de ce qui se passe dans le
monde financier à londres est réparti
entre stuttgart francfort enfin bon
bruxelles et paris bon on va être un peu
gagnant là dessus mais je crois pas
qu'il y aura dû à un vrai gagnant
totalement là dessus on n'a pas intérêt
nous avons vraiment intérêt à continuer
à faire des choses ensemble malgré tout
même s'ils sont hors de l'europe qui
vont devenir un partenaire extérieur
merci beaucoup d'être venu à réagir sur
notre un plateau ladislas poniatowski
sénateur à l'est républicain et
rapporteur de la commission spéciale sur
la bioéthique au sénat